you guys are really free-range parents
like you guys really weren't strict we
could pretty much like
I don't want to say do whatever we
wanted because there was always like
obviously limits but you guys what do
you think the benefits are to free-range
parenting more because you know everyone
turned out okay you know we're okay I
think
jazz
is Chaz really the issue here Adam
so do you do you think that's better
than being like super strict with the
kids
I think it depends on the kid okay
honestly some kids like
so yeah it does for sure so actually
I'll tell a hard story but
of course
so you can do it so from an animus 14.
he's
nah I can't do it yet yeah okay I think
that um when you think about
um parent like how I think about
parenting is that kids today they can't
make any decisions so they get into
adulthood and they've never had any
practice and so so it's like they're
overgrown children they're overgrown
children and so you know and and I know
when like our first kids like I was
definitely far more of a helicopter
parent than with me with the old the
younger ones yeah I mean just like
bedtimes and what you ate and how you
drive oh I just I meant when like I was
in high school you guys no but I'm
saying like as when you were young oh
okay yeah as well I was kind of
overwhelmed by the time you were in high
school to be honest because there's a
lot of kids oh yeah because I wasn't it
wasn't super strict when I was growing
up I don't think but the catch was like
this when Adam was 14 he always said you
never listen to me first
foreign
I was always right first but no one ever
no one ever listened to me they just
kind of blew me off and every time I was
right I'd say [ __ ] you guys I Told You
So and well and so he became just the
opposite he was a pain in the ass so he
finally did that he changed to be a
different kid
and so that's the point is that you have
to deal with the kid and based on that I
mean like Eva too you just gotta deal
with it's a personality yeah each kid is
different and different personalities
and that's such how do you deal with
them you can't there's no there's no set
mold yeah at least not die of so like
some kids need more structure than
others exactly and some and some new
less and some of these things we listen
to and some need to be
[Laughter]
that's the point you can't you just know
there's no set I mean some kids need to
be strict I mean just do I mean chance I
think no King how are you able because
one thing that I always get a lot is
like we grew up in like a one percent
family but we don't really act like a
like super stuck up and snotty because
because even
um growing up like there's one comment
that I felt like really resembled our
family in the comment section it was
like y'all are rich but you look broke
I wore my nicest shirt today I just want
to make this clear hey that's only like
Starbucks so how do you oh he likes oh
yeah he likes Hot Chocolate you buy
Starbucks now he never used to and I
think like it's obviously different
based on the kid but like overall I
would say we're pretty down to earth
family how did you keep us like that
even though we grew up with money so but
we didn't I mean LeBron James a good
comment he told his son that no son
you're not rich I am no Shaquille
Shaquille Shack checked it okay what I'm
sorry one of the famous basketball
players but the point was it's those
same we never really we didn't go in
expensive vacations we went on vacations
where we drove we took out we did our
own food we did everything as if I mean
I guess it's because she's cheap I I
would spend money okay
I think yeah like a part of it too
Hannah is that it goes back to the
comment about who you marry like work
ethic is really important we don't work
less today than we ever did we don't
treat money differently today than we
ever to you know do we have more money
sure but I don't value it less I don't
you know I work just as hard I don't
have any extra and so are you sure yeah
yeah
but I think that you know that work
ethic like Dan and I both grew up when
our families didn't have much our
parents gave us nothing and that was the
best gift for the record you know I was
going at 17. oh you're gone at 17. I was
young so yeah I was gone at 17 too yeah
so so just you guys know okay
because that's the other thing is it's I
didn't realize how all of my siblings
like work hard and that's like something
you guys really taught us was like even
even like I don't want to say even my
laziest sibling is harder working than
like the average person that I'm not
gonna give names
but even my laziest sibling I would say
is harder working than like the average
person I meet and I think the other
thing too is first letter yeah okay like
everyone there's always a first and a
laugh like I'm not gonna one letter fits
three so yeah
um so what I was gonna say is that I
think everybody
everybody's kind like they all all know
how to be kind and they know how to be
helpful so not only just hard working
but helpful and I know you know I've
gotten messages from teachers I got one
from Amelia's teacher this year you know
about just going out of her way to help
another kid and Eva I know there's
dozens of stories and actually there's
stories about you that I could tell that
were super sweet and just so beyond your
years and I think that you know that's
another just difference in how you guys
were raised you were you know I don't
want to say you're forced to be helpful
but the the
combination of being from a giant family
and hard-working parents you had to be
helpful you didn't have a choice yeah it
was the only way we got attention
probably not out of the line yeah
probably true yeah no because that's the
one thing I always I always credit like
you guys to a lot of like like obviously
I would never have built this show if I
didn't have you guys supporting me and I
always say like I would be nothing
without my family and like the people
that like supported me and I I'm just
amazed um you guys drive me nuts I'm not
gonna lie to you everyone all of you but
like at the end of the day like I know I
have really great people at home and I
know that like my family is always going
to be there for me no matter what and I
just you know I always really
appreciated how hard you guys worked
because a lot of the times I don't know
if everyone really appreciated how like
especially you Mom with like our family
trips going up I would be so annoyed
that I had to like leave for half the
summer but like looking back like I'm so
grateful I have those memories like with
you guys and with my siblings and it
really taught me to be like humble you
know because like I was always so
jealous of my friends that were like on
planes you know that would fly to their
vacations because I I'm like I have to
go with this van with all my siblings
this is so but like like looking back
like I think it's really character
building
to deal with other siblings in a van
well you know I think everyone on in our
family knows how to get along with
people because we had to we have 10
different personalities and sometimes we
want to kill each other but like but we
love each other at the end of the day
yeah no I think that I mean there's a
lot there that's a there's a lot of
different things but it's part of why we
did vacation well that and we just
either didn't have the money at the time
or didn't want to spend the money but
you know it's
okay I was gonna say the best uh the
best story was you know maybe a decade
or so ago we were looking into upgrading
we have a the big red boss and the Big
Red Bus has uh uh 335
000 miles on it so we've driven it a lot
and we were looking at upgrading it and
thinking about that that's what we're
gonna do and Amelia said we can't do
that that's